this is madagascar's capital
antananarivo
much of it submerged underwater after
days of unrelenting rainfall
two storms sent water rushing through
these streets
resident pierre michelle shows the
damage left in the wake
the power is cut in this area we have to
deal with that and the floods we're
never at peace everyone is affected not
only my home but all the houses in this
neighborhood
neighbor vivian does her best to clear
the water
her family is staying for now
billiard fans are neat the water came in
and we didn't know how to get it out of
the house so we put the kids on the bunk
bed my husband and i then sorted through
our stuff to see the damage
local officials are asking people to
leave their homes
and join thousands of others at
established shelters
we've set up the first shelters to
receive the victims and the municipality
will take care of them we call on all
disaster victims to leave their homes
and go to the shelters
this school gymnasium is providing
short-term refuge
most of those who escaped say their
homes were swept away or destroyed
part of our house has collapsed we ask
for help we can't live at home because
it's flooded if we leave here we have
nowhere to go
our house was flooded twice the first
time we stayed there but this time we
had to leave because the mattresses are
wet and our baby got sick
it's not unusual to see heavy rain
during the wet season but this was
exceptional
with more than 100 millimeters of
rainfall in just one day
20 districts are now on high alert
and people living in impoverished areas
with poor drainage are more vulnerable
to flooding
many rescue teams have now taken boats
to navigate the high waters
others are organizing fresh water
supplies hygiene packs and food
as many are now vulnerable to waterborne
diseases
from the sky it's clear how much work
needs to be done
as thousands of homes remain submerged
and the forecast shows more rainfall now
on the horizon
laura burdenmanly al jazeera